in this lecture we introduced the
Poisson process which is a
continuous-time analogue of the
Bernoulli process one way of thinking
about it is as follows time is
continuous but conceptually we divided
into a very large number of slots and
during each slot we have a tiny
probability of an arrival this
probability is proportional to the
length of the slot furthermore we have
an independence assumption for the
different slots the Poisson process is a
very elegant model of arrival processes
in continuous-time it models many
real-world phenomena and it also has a
very clean mathematical structure that
allows us to calculate practically every
quantity of interest our development
will parallel our analysis of the
Bernoulli process for example we will
find the PMF of the number of arrivals
during a time interval and the PDF of
the time of the case arrival we will
discuss the memorylessness properties of
the poisson process similar to the case
of the Bernoulli process this is just a
consequence of the independence
assumptions that we are making
we will then exploit these independence
properties to argue that the inter
arrival times are independent
exponential random variables and we will
conclude with a comprehensive example